good morning john is how we start these
videos you don't like throw that in a
couple of sentences into the video and
expect to not hear about it anyway
there's a pretty big problem that i
think i have come up with a good
solution to you know how when you put
your foot inside of a shoe it doesn't
feel great it can be like bumpy in there
and a little rough and like the foot
sweat builds up i have invented a
product that goes between your foot and
your shoe it's like a kind of foot
sleeve it's stretchy in cotton and you
pull it up on over your foot before you
put your shoe on and then boom it
cushions your foot it absorbs the foot
sweat and you can even wear them without
shoes just to keep your feet warm around
the house now this is a really new idea
but i think there's a chance that it
could really catch on which brings up
something that i've been wanting to talk
about for a while when you or i have an
idea like something that we would like
to bring into the world we're not
entirely in control of what that idea
needs to look like no individual humans
are in charge what is in charge is a set
of values and expectations that this
community shares when appealing ideas
mesh with those values amazing things
can and have happened and that's a
really big part of like what we do here
because i think that foot sleeves could
be a really big deal but you can't just
do foot sleeves the normal way if it's
going to be a project from this
community you have to do it in some way
that is exceptional and finds ways to be
in concert with the values let's say for
example that it's a subscription where
you can sign up and get foot sleeves in
your mail every month each one designed
by a different independent artist and
also instead of being open all the time
with all of the inventory problems and
excess waste that that can create it's
only open during very limited windows
and also because this community is much
more interested in solving long-term
problems than it is in short-term profit
you donate all of the profit to help
build more robust healthcare systems and
impoverished communities so now it is
time for me to abandon the conceit that
i uh invented socks especially because
this will be the second year of the
awesome socks globby sock subscription
for charity that this community has
helped energize and activate with its
values and its goals and its mission so
much so that it has allowed it to grow
outside of this community and we project
that we're going to donate over 900 000
to charity this year and also because
the yearly opening of the sock club
starts today and it goes only for the
next nine days if you click on the link
in the description you can sign up to
get a pair of socks designed by a
different independent artist delivered
to you every month shipping is free and
you can cancel any time and yes every
dollar of profit goes to support our
community's work decreasing maternal and
child mortality in sierra leone there is
one thing that has changed in our second
year last year we set it up as a
one-year subscription six months in we
discovered that the majority of people
thought that it was a perpetual
subscription so if you are an early
adopter to the sock club you will need
to renew if you want to keep getting
your socks uh starting on january of
2022. to do that just go into your email
and search for an email that i sent you
just search hank green in your inbox if
you don't have that email you don't need
to do anything moving forward the
awesome socks club is perpetual but you
can still cancel any time just to avoid
that confusion but you can also get a
gift subscription if you want a
subscription that will automatically
cancel after 12 months imagine how
revolutionary an idea socks would be if
they had not been invented yet we would
be so excited about that but this
community did not invent socks what it
did do is with its values and with its
activation and excitement it invented
like a new way to do socks instead of
the way where you have to think too much
about it and stand around awkwardly in
the target underwear section and then it
being not that cool looking anyway and
all the profit goes to some stranger you
let the experts take care of it with a
delightful surprise delivered to you
once a month and 100 compostable
packaging and yes all of the profit goes
to make the world a better place just
out here solving problems the
nerdfighter way there's a link in the
description john i'll see you on tuesday